There's three simplifications that we'll introduce to make analyzing algorithms easier for us.
The first one is we will talk about a way that we can analyze algorithms without actually having
to implement them, which we already that a lot of times.
The second simplification is going to be that we're not going to consider all possible inputs
that an algorithm can be run on, but we're going to only consider the worst possible inputs
and I'll say more about what that means too.
And finally, I'll introduce a notation to you called Big O-notation that will allow us to ignore
details that for now we'll call unnecessary, so that we can really focus on the parts
that are important for an algorithm and ignore those that we're not interested in.
What do these simplifications actually look like or how are we going
to go about those simplifications.
First of all, to analyze an algorithm without implementing, we're going to consider
a special kind of computer, which is not really a computer but a model that comes pretty close
and that model is called the RAM.
Looking at the worst possible inputs is a concept called worst-case running time,
and finally to be able to ignore all unnecessary details, we'll use a type of notation
called Big O-notation or Landau notation.
So let's start out with our theoretical computer called the RAM.